[Music]
the Justin Bieber thing upset she would
all do you feel I mean this is a guy
he's getting a lot of attention I have
no problem with any of his behavior like
if I was his age and you know I had like
you know what what does he have a I
don't know what he has a Ferrari a
Lamborghini something like that yeah
yeah every check out there wants to bang
you like how are you supposed to how are
you supposed to behave limo he beat up
me as a limo driver at 19 and he's not
like going to a prom it's like he's
going to an arena where he puts for you
in his days his behavior is completely
normal
the only thing I didn't like was that
that that shot what he was playing hoop
yes it was it was a it went viral I
think he was in basketball and he took a
shot yeah he went in he was playing with
this black friend that he's paying to
lose wins he's out of the entourage
like you know his phone was blown up
this whole week like this and you don't
understand how it works I have to lose
hey I got to get a job so I just didn't
like I didn't like he hit a layup here
like a 12 footer and then he turns
around and he's like glaring at the
camera like I said he couldn't do it or
something like that he looks into the
camera like I showed all of you I never
saw Jordan do that there is like he just
did something it didn't even look like
the net was regulation it looks like now
it's just watching it having empathy for
him going yeah that's what I would be
doing I'm surprised he's not doing blow
that's what I would have done right and
then I get that look and I was just like
you know what you know F this guy yeah
because he's gonna look back he's gonna
look back and be I should've done this
she's 19 years old like I'm rootin for
okay I think that's a nice thing it is I
think that's a nice thing